mr joins me now um do you think mr
bryant
that you've got a satisfactory answer to
your question
do you no obviously not i mean
you know i think sometimes
it's perfectly legitimate if a minister
gets something wrong
um by accident they misspoke or whatever
they should just they have an
opportunity to correct the record and
that's where i started with the prime
minister why why do you never correct
the record because there's so many cases
when you know just looking at the facts
he's not he's not told us the truth he's
told lies
and and when he refuses to correct the
record then it becomes a deliberate lie
in my mind and and that was the problem
that i was trying to get to he waffled
on about the
350 million pounds on the side of the
bus uh which incidentally he was told
off categorically by the uk
statistics authority for as a clear
misuse of official statistics
but but there's a simple point here he's
trying to pretend now that he sacked
matt hancock he clearly said he said
that
he heard about it on the friday and by
saturday we had a new health secretary
that's true yeah that's a line
isn't it that it's not an answer to the
question did you see that's not an
answer to the question no but it's it's
not a lie it that's
what happens it is a lie it is a lie
because what he actually said at the
time he's trying to
muddy the waters um and that makes it an
obfuscatory lie
it's not the direct lie of course but it
is an obfuscation and a deliberately
a deliberate hiding of the truth because
what did he what did he actually say at
the time
that this matter was closed well that
that you know he he is
remarkable in the number of times that
he's told fibs i mean it's about
um co2 emissions he's he he's told flips
in the house of commons
um the relative poverty uh under labour
or under
conservatives and nurses bursaries he
told fibs about that
and the government's record on the nhs
which he said was
a record um uh investment when in actual
fact the figure was much higher
under labor um and now this issue about
matt hancock but
you know it's it i it's i know some
people say
to me quite often um voters don't care
about this stuff
um that's not the issue for me the issue
for me is
does the prime minister care about
standards in public life
or not and that's why i wanted to
suggest for instance that there's a
problem here that we have one set of
rules for the government
and a completely different set of rules
for other people he seemed to think that
the
matt hancock issue was not an issue um
that required
resignation um and then
24 hours later when lots of new
information came out
of course it became inevitable he didn't
sack him
he resigned hmm and now we found
ourselves in a situation where we do
have a new health secretary and
everything
um is going to open up
um on the 19th uh the pm in pmsq said
that it was reasonable
how they've opened up um the labour
leader has a very different
take on it uh what do you think
two things first of all obviously we're
just talking about england here i'm a
welsh mp so we have slightly different
arrangements in wales and
uh i think mark drakeford has approached
things with a much more rational
uh sensible approach than uh boris
johnson has in england
um but the second point i'd say is if
people
are still going to have to isolate um
when
they are pinged by the app or when
they're in
close contact with somebody who's had
covet and we have got a hundred thousand
cases a day which is what the government
itself is predicting
so seven hundred thousand a week that is
going to be somewhere in the region of 4
million people
self-isolating for 10 days every week
all the way until the middle of august
now that's obviously going to be
lots of holidays may be affected that
doesn't matter maybe
so much as the fact that supermarkets
are going to struggle if 20
of their staff are not able to come in
um the nhs is going to struggle if 20
of its staff is unable to come in and
most of our public services are going to
struggle if 20
of their staff are unable to come in so
i think what we've got now is the worst
of all possible worlds
i i desperately want us to be able to
get to a point where we can open up
but you cannot have illogical
inconsistent and reckless rules in place
and and just on the position of masks i
hate mars
i loathe wearing a mask um but
it i'm not doing it for me i'm doing it
for others and that's why you need
an approach which is we're all in this
together we all take common decisions
and that's why i think the government
really does need to review this issue
um of keeping masks in place um for a
little bit longer it's interesting when
you bring up this issue with mars
because
a lot of people say when you actually
look at the policy of labour yes
a lot of your mps have come out and even
kistama has come out and said this isn't
how it should be done
you know this opening up on the 19th and
then this delay until the 16th
but when you look at your policy it
seems that actually the only thing that
you would do differently is
the issue of masks how would you
approach things
differently well this is one area i just
wouldn't
release everything at the same time
because each element that you release
and sort of unpacks another element of
risk into the equation
and doing all of them at the same time i
think is reckless and i think it's been
done
because the prime minister is he's so
focused on this idea of himself being
the
the jovial jolly chap in britain who's
coming to bring hope to everybody like
a latter day um jesus christ but
actually
um i think far more sensible is really
to drill down
on the uh on the on the
the data rather than the dates and he
just always got fixed on the dates
because he wants to have a big full
house of commons sitting behind him on
the tory benches
and two days after the 19th of july i i
i sometimes despair the of the approach
she takes
and and some of the policies that he's
now got are just completely and utterly
impractical
this issue of what you're doing about
pinging people is completely
impractical and i think it's likely to
lead to people and
simply breaking the law and and that's
the worst of all possible worlds
okay mr brian thank you so much you're
gonna have to leave it there but thanks
a lot for talking to us
thank you